i got
hundreds of texts obviously about the
commercial but just being like do you
know how
cool it is that you were in a super bowl
commercial right i didn't i didn't
realize that many eyeballs locked into
one thing at one time like it really
doesn't happen other than the super bowl
yeah it was a very cool moment and it
was you know it's like every time you
think you're done with the sopranos like
there's always just something else that
comes back up
um but if it is canon
then theoretically what do you what does
that mean what do you mean like he says
it a lot cannon
like meaning that it counts for the
storyline like there's all the episodes
of the series and the prequel and the
car commercial pretty boss like whether
she's a boss the boss of something you
imagine
the trauma that those kids went through
if that guy got shot in his head in the
diner right in front of him while they
were sitting right there i would love
nothing more unless she was walking in
there's a spin-off and we're doing it
like yeah i would love to continue to
play meta honestly as we were shooting
the commercial i sat and we're kind of
you know action and david's there and i
was like i could drop into this girl in
a heartbeat you were already there like
i know who she is as an adult yep i knew
it and it was a cool feeling so i mean i
don't think it'll ever happen but it was
cool to do it for even a minute was she
still married to patsy's son no
wow
we had to be very thoughtful and i had
said to david do you think she's wearing
a wedding ring
because people are going to be looking
for these types of things and he's like
uh yeah
maybe she definitely didn't marry
patsy's son though he did tell me that
oh [ __ ] he said no way she went through
with that that's incredible so he kind
of so he knows these things that he
didn't actually put in the final script
he does so well it's not i don't think
he gave it so much thought until that
moment but it was like oh
yeah no no no no
or maybe they did and that didn't work
out like he said he's like she's not
married to him
[Music]